from The Daily Mail says female job
Seekers at a women in Tech conference
have reacted with Fury after a number of
men crashed the networking events
seemingly taking advantage of the
acceptance of non-binary people the
Scandal erupted at the Grace Hopper
celebration of women in Computing in
Orlando Florida uh which is among the
most lucrative job finding conventions
for young female professionals to meet
major Tech firms often right out of
college this year Summit held from
September 26 to 29th was swarmed with
men also looking to land a big interview
with firms including Amazon Apple and
Google the reason many were welcomed
appeared to be the women's event
allowing non-binary individuals to also
attend sparking anger among women
feeling the move was a Shameless attempt
to take advantage of gender diversity
programs Furious attendees took to
social media to slam the men for gate
crashing the women's event however some
pointed the finger at vague benchmarks
for entering the summit as men could
simply identify as non-binary so there's
a lot of outrage about this on the
internet it was all quite hilarious uh
here's a report from uh an outlet called
catchup news which shows us some of the
some of the women who are not so pleased
about this career conference for females
in Tech was taken over by m attendees
they were there just purely for the
career fair social media Clips filmed at
the Grace Hopper the world's largest
gathering of women technologists show
men standing in line to meet with
recruiters this is a space for women in
Tech this is one of those few limited
resources that isn't for you it's for us
some of the male attendees reportedly
lied about being non-binary just to get
in but it's interesting that the large
majority of the people that actually
ended up in the event had name tags with
he him and have no searchable history of
identifying as non-binary several Tech
workers defended the men for trying to
capitalize on job opportunities not
meant for them seeing that the entire
concept was wrong let's be honest there
is no need for a conference just for
women because if it was the opposite for
men then it would be sexist just because
you are a woman doesn't give you the
right to talk to a big firm recruiter
guys work just as hard and they don't
get that
chance no searchable history of
identifying as non-binary what do you
mean what searchable history what did
have you been identifying every single
one of these guys and uh or not guys
they don't identify as guys have you
been Have You Been identifying every
single one of these they thems and then
going online to search to find out
exactly when they started identifying as
nonbinary uh if you are then then uh
you're you're a creep but
also uh that's highly bigoted because
first of all if someone decided this
morning that they're non-binary that is
a totally valid
identity and also there's no rules in
the non the non-binary rule book last I
checked that says that if you're
non-binary you have to go by they them
pronouns you go by he him pronouns you
go you could go by any pronoun you could
use no pronoun you could make up a
pronoun these are the rules the rules
are that there are no
rules um and we'll talk more about that
in a second but we also uh we should
also note that the uh I think it's this
the title is Chief impact officer I
believe guy named Colin Colin white uh
was was at the event and he actually at
some point the the the invasion of
non-binary men got to a point where it
was a real crisis at the event so the
chief impact officer stood up and called
out the men from the stage let's watch
some of that this is supposed to be a
joyous event that cers around you
yesterday it became clear that there are
a far greater number of cisgender men
attending to
anticipate simply put some of you lied
about your gender identity when you
register it has evidence by Stacks and
stacks of resumes you're passing out you
did so because you thought thought that
you could come here and take space to
try to get a
job we need male
allies we need men who want to celebrate
women who want to work with and for
women and so we welcome men in this SP
but to learn and support
and
improve let's pause
it needless to say um I am well first of
all I am deeply
inspired um by what these heroic
non-binary men have done breaking down
barriers crashing through glass ceilings
and
um and to see the bigotry that they
encountered to be called out from the
stage and when I think about how deeply
otherizing and marginalizing it must
have been for them uh it it it just it
makes me Furious it makes me Furious to
see
that uh and
listen you know they have the leftover a
barrel on this one there's there's
there's really nothing you can say you
you invented this non-binary idea you
intentionally made it incoherent
ambiguous totally impossible to Define
arbitrary um you're the ones who
declared that being non-binary or being
trans carries with it no standards or or
requirements of any
kind uh you certainly can't make
determinations about what who someone is
and what their identity is just by
looking at
them you
said if you say that you're non-binary
then you are and that's
it uh what what does it mean to be
non-binary like to look at someone and
say well I don't I don't think they're
really non-binary what do you mean
really
non-binary it's it literally is nothing
nothing it's just it's just a it's just
a phrase that you
use that's the rule that you set up so
it makes no sense for you to sit there
and say that these men aren't non-binary
or or aren't presenting themselves as
non-binary that's my favorite thing
about this is that they're they're
they're getting they're getting blamed
for not presenting what do you mean
presenting
yourself and you have no right to say
that like according to you according to
you you have no right to to tell anyone
that they that they are or are not
non-binary how dare you how dare
you I say again how dare you
marginalize these non-binary
Americans who are trying to get jobs in
Tech let me ask you this how many Tech
CEOs are non-b
Ary I mean there's probably a lot at
this point to be fair but but you know
not not enough not nearly
enough and so these brave souls show up
to this
conference living their
Truth for many of them you know what it
probably is the first time that they Liv
their truth openly you couldn't find a
searchable history of them being
non-binary you know what it probably is
true all of these uh former men all
together decide
in that moment that they were going to
announce themselves to the world in
their true non-binary
form at a at a at a career
conference think about the courage that
required and and and they do that and
then this is the response they get from
these bigoted liberal women I am shocked
I am
appalled
um but all I could say to these men is H
is or or former men or whatever they
want to be called you know what here's
the thing they it's possible that they
still identify as men that they still go
by he him
pronouns they still dress like men
everything is the same everything is the
same and yet they they are also
non-binary that that's that's
valid um so to these men if that's what
they identify as um I can only just
extend my my heartfelt um admiration and
and I also uh very much encourage um
other men who randomly identifies
non-binary to invade um any conference
you know like
this
um uh giving the left a chance to you
know
experience experience the full
implications of their own ideology I
think it's it's a good opportunity it's
an opportunity for them to experience
and you know something too many of these
women at this
conference for for the for the first
time in
years they they suddenly discovered what
the word woman
means so maybe that is the great service
that these men or former men uh provided
to these women just by showing up by
simply showing up all of these liberal
women in
Tech all together discovered what the
word woman
means very brave very brave if You' like
to see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there godp speed